hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel and today I am going to be
unboxing this thing which is obviously a
giant dildo as I'm sure you already know
my channel is all about finding the
coolest giant dildos that we can and
this one isn't even themed but actually
it's an amiibo stand I got into the mail
and the idea is that it's a really cute
way to display some your amiibo so
that's what it's supposed to look like I
have no idea how big this thing is so
why don't we assemble it okay
judging by this it's going to be very
big and I think that you assemble it
sort of like a Lego I might get on the
floor for this one
so this is obviously an extremely easy
setup I just thought that I would show
you guys the top of the blocks they have
circles cut out of them a because that's
how you connect one together kind of
like Lego but also I presume that it is
the right size for your amiibo so you
can slot them right in there and they
won't move so I'm just gonna go get some
of my amiibo to see how they look in the
displaced in so I just pulled up a bunch
of amoeba you can merely fill it with
old Mario at me boats are just gonna
slug them in you excuse me
you make it very hard to see and they
all fit in perfectly I think this is a
super cute way to display your amiibo of
especially when you have a Labrador in
the background and I made the flag the
color scheme I think the whole thing is
really nice and I feel like using my
Mario amiibo is a particularly fitting
way to show it off
of course main criticism would be that
you know and they fit six can you
imagine if this was you know a lot wider
it would be epic I mean I suppose
there's no reason that you can't buy
multiple of them but it doesn't seem to
have any kind of snap together to
support several of them but who actually
only has six amiibo if nobody has just
six it's 15 inches tall and 18 inches
wide or 38 centimeters tall and 45 25
centimeters wide and I wouldn't
recommend displaying it on the butt of
your Labrador because
it moves a lot if you do that and it is
officially licensed in tender product
but it does mention on the back that
certain with larger sized and me my
thing is that may not fit so this is
obviously a really short video today but
I think this isn't a really cool-looking
thing so I thought that I would share it
with you guys anyway I'm a lot of thank
you guys for watching my channel and I
hope you appreciate the dog cameo that
just just destroyed it actually she just
actually destroyed you destroyed it you
just you just you killed Silva Mario
interesting he's dead he's dead oh oh
they're all dead know that everyone
everyone's getting killed she killed
over there all day are you serious
Chelsea footage - Chelsea what did you
do what have you done hmm
it's okay you're beautiful idiot it's
fine I'm not mad